[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de France 24 en español de
actualidad europea yo soy Esther Herrera
caro desde el parlamento europeo en
Bruselas es un placer saludarles en el
programa de hoy hablamos justo cuando
queda un año para las elecciones al
parlamento europeo nos preguntamos Qué
se ha hecho hasta ahora en la Unión
Europea y que queda aún por aprobar lo
analizamos con dos eurodiputados que han
tenido recorridos distintos en esta
institución Por una parte Antonio López
eurodiputado del partido popular europeo
desde hace casi 20 años bienvenido
Antonio Muchas gracias y con evapop se
va que se ha incorporado esta misma
legislatura del grupo renovar Europa
bienvenida Eva Hola Muchas gracias a los
dos por estar aquí como comentábamos
ambos tenéis visiones un poco distintas
de esta institución propuesta de
trayectoria pero esta legislatura además
ha sido un poco compleja un poco también
distinta porque apenas hecho andar y
estalló la pandemia la primera
emergencia mundial de este Calibre en
100 años ahora con la vista atrás
Antonio ya que se ha dejado la
emergencia sanitaria cambiarías algo de
la gestión de esta pandemia a nivel
europeo
es fácil decirlo muy fácil ahora ahora
viene los gurús no diciendo ya lo dije
yo y tal y decir No creo que fíjate
cuando En aquellos tiempos se hablaba de
que las vacunas se tardan varios años en
conseguir no y tal y cual y aquí se
consiguen un año es decir se volcó
totalmente Úrsula wonderlay en la
comisión europea todos nosotros y Oye
creo que efectividad ha habido se ha
coordinado muchísimas políticas por
ejemplo pongamos el caso en tema de
transporte los estados miembros cerraron
las fronteras sin avisar a nadie España
cerró fronteras con Francia aquello era
un caos que pasó que a las dos semanas
se dieron cuenta de que los
supermercados se quedaban vacíos Oiga
porque no pasaban los camiones que pasa
vino todos a llorar a Bruselas y
Bruselas puso los pasillos verdes para
que por fin para que la gente pudiese
comer y tener los artículos de primera
necesidad tú estás tipo de cosas que
como siempre no ocupan titulares nunca
se sabe de ello pero que contribuyó a
capear el temporal perfecto como en
otros países no pudieron hacerlo
desgraciadamente no fuera de nuestra
órbita O sea que creo que bueno en fin
que se podía haber hecho mejor como
siempre en la vida Pues claro Hay
muchísimas más cosas que se podían haber
hecho mejor pero creo que bastante bien
Ahora el covid hablas del tema
parlamento europeo ha sido un pequeño
desastre porque el contacto entre
diputados italianos alemanes eslovenos
búlgaros
es fundamental el contacto personal
verse por imágenes no genera esa calidez
europea
ese contacto que al final ve que todos
somos iguales que no somos raros que no
que los españoles no es todo flamenco
que los franceses no son todos no sé qué
y que los suecos no van con cuernos no y
tal es decir como los vikingos que es la
imagen un poco de esos prejuicios de
tantos siglos decir pues se van
venciendo con el contacto personal y eso
ha sido difícil difícil
Eva Esta es la comisión además de
economía aquí del parlamento europeo uno
de los momentos clave fue la creación
del plan de recuperación un fondo de
750.000 millones de euros que tuvo un
enfoque muy distinto al que se había
dado hasta ahora el anterior crisis la
de 2008 que pretende Por una parte salir
de las consecuencias económicas de la
pandemia a la vez se trata también de
transformar las economías europeas visto
en perspectiva es el plan adecuado
realmente es el plan que se prevía en un
principio Pues la verdad es que ha sido
un paso histórico no O sea además que
reaccionamos rápidamente
a esta pandemia con las medidas
económicas este fondo como como
comentabas de 750 mil millones de euros
es una cantidad Ya sé que es un poco
difícil cuando le hablas a la gente de
estas cantidades pero es enorme es
básicamente otro presupuesto de la Unión
Europea y es una es un paso histórico
además que se muy rápidamente aquí en la
Unión Europea
si ha sido a mí lo que no digamos con
las lecciones ahora prendidas del del
fondo de cooperación
creo que no lo diseñamos Pero esto
digamos digamos o cómo es por culpa de
los gobiernos de los estados miembros no
está diseñado de una forma perfecta
porque digo esto porque básicamente lo
que se dijo Es que hay que dar este
dinero rápidamente a los gobiernos para
que puedan hacer las inversiones
necesarias para digamos transformar
modernizar nuestras sociedades
modernizar nuestro tejido productivo
pero realmente sin ningún el control es
muy es muy escaso no Y entonces lo que
estamos viendo Es que muchos gobiernos
también el nuestro Pues realmente por
ejemplo no saben decirte cuánto dinero
ha llegado a la economía real tenemos
muy poco tiempo para ejecutar los fondos
de recuperación la contratación se tiene
que hacer hasta finales de este año 20 y
23 después la ejecución se puede hacer
hasta 20 y 26 y digamos de todos los
fondos solamente se han
digamos los estados miembros han
obtenido un 30% y ya no queda mucho
mucho tiempo y en el caso de España por
ejemplo el dato de ejecución no está
nada Claro no sabemos Cuánto dinero ha
llegado realmente a los beneficiarios
finales no a empresas y a ciudadanos
justo cuando la Unión Europea dejaba
tras la pandemia estalló la guerra en
Ucrania que ha supuesto un cambio
tectónico para la Unión Europea se han
tomado decisiones como la ayuda para el
envío de armas la protección de los
refugiados también ahora Ucrania es un
país candidato es factible que Ucrania
se convierta en un nuevo país miembro de
la Unión Europea ahora estaba girando la
cabeza porque pasaba por ahí el
expresidente de Ucrania petroporo
estamos aquí en el estudio en el
parlamento europeo no y
hemos estado Yo creo Al principio de la
invasión realmente la sociedad europea
estuvo muy por encima de la clase
política
yo debo admitir
seguimos con una falta de Liderazgo
todavía a nivel de Estados miembros y de
Unión Europea yo se ha citado antes Mis
años de servicio en este parlamento
europeo y en otras instituciones
europeas y de noto en estos momentos
todavía una cierta falta de Liderazgo
para los tiempos que corren hace falta
mucho más
Úrsula wonderlayen lo ha demostrado lo
intenta pero los estados miembros ahí
noto muchas reticencias en el tema de
Ucrania por ejemplo se nota se ve en el
tema de reparto de gastos de defensa no
en la ayuda al pueblo ucraniano a ver
cuándo entienden algunos sobre todo en
nuestro país en España que está en estos
momentos a nivel Nueva Zelanda en cuanto
a aportación en ayuda a Ucrania cuidado
que el dato es tremendo es decir que los
ucranianos en estos momentos están
luchando por lo que nosotros ya tenemos
democracia y libertad y si fallan los
siguientes somos nosotros
a ver si esto ya germina en algunos
gobiernos especialmente en el de España
donde tienen de vez en cuando algún show
se van a visitar por ahí aviones y tal y
cual Pero la realidad de las cosas que
en estos momentos tenemos que estar
mucho más activos y presentes porque
vuelvo a insistir la defensa de Ucrania
es nuestra defensa no solo territorial
sino de nuestros principios y valores Y
eso implica que Ucrania se pueda
convertir en país miembro de la Unión
Europea en un futuro
indudablemente se ha empezado ya ese
camino se ha empezado ahora Ucrania era
un país ya antes de la guerra con una
situación económica terrible un grado de
corrupción enorme y Yo sé que trabajarlo
entonces hay que trabajarlo con selensky
y con todo la clase política ucraniana
actualmente democráticamente elegida
habrá elecciones probablemente A lo
mejor en otoño es decir trabajar mucho
para poder condicionar todo para que sea
ese proceso lo más rápido posible
actualmente si uno ve los datos
fríamente tiende a pensar que entre el
proceso de reconstrucción y la situación
que había anterior pudiese tardar más
tiempo trabajemos para que no sea así y
que Ucrania sea cuanto antes miembro de
esta Unión Europea
también como consecuencia de la guerra
en Ucrania la Unión Europea ha reducido
también su dependencia de hidrocarburos
de Rusia ha acelerado la transición
energética está a la vista puesta en el
2050 para que el continente se convierta
en climáticamente
neutro realmente lo va a poder conseguir
ya con la vista puesta ya en el futuro
Eva es nuestro
y ahí hablamos de la autonomía
estratégica no todo el mundo ahora habla
de la autonomía estratégica Pero la
verdad es que no estamos siendo
coherentes con este discurso no O sea
todos sabemos que tenemos que conseguir
una Independencia energética pero parece
un tabú yo siempre lo digo en la Unión
Europea hablar de producción energética
en el suelo de la Unión Europea estamos
siempre hablando de diversificación las
fuentes de suministro prácticamente lo
que significa es de donde importamos gas
o gas líquido pero no hablamos realmente
de producir energía en suelo europeo y
cuando vemos ahora las estadísticas
desde el año 2020 básicamente ha
aumentado muchísimo el consumo de
carbono nuestras industrias ahora mismo
están necesitando muchísima muchísimo
muchísimo carbono no Alemania por
ejemplo ha aumentado el uso muchísimo en
otros dos miembros mientras el uso por
ejemplo de energía nuclear ha bajado y
cuando hablamos de esta Independencia
energética pues tenemos que ver posible
y que es necesario para hacer esta
transición energética No yo esta semana
pasada he estado en España en muchísimas
he visitado varias empresas
fotovoltaicas y todos me decían lo mismo
o sea tenemos una huella de carbono muy
importante por la necesidad de trabajar
con acero y tenemos que ver cómo
compensamos esta huella y básicamente
hay dos posibilidades con hidrógeno para
producir este acero y trabajarlo y
energía nuclear Entonces yo creo que
algunos han descartado la energía
nuclear demasiado pronto cuando la
necesitamos para esta transición
energética y para esta Independencia
energética que necesitamos
conseguir y básicamente hay dos sectores
muy estratégicos en la Unión Europea
estamos hablando de la guerra y también
en general no de la excepción de la
Unión Europea y una de ellas es el
sector energético otro quizás
la defensa el sector de
telecomunicaciones pero si no los
tratamos como sectores
la verdad es que nunca conseguiremos
esta Independencia nos queda muy poco
tiempo pero también quiero hablar un
poquito también del futuro se espera la
presencia de España del Consejo de la
Unión Europea a partir de Julio uno de
los puntos principales va a ser la
Cumbre entre la Unión Europea y los
países de la celac es un momento clave
con Brasil pidiendo paz en Ucrania se
está pendiente de los acuerdos con
México chile también con mercosur va a
ser la Unión Europea por fin la que mire
América Latina en esta legislatura Bueno
pues es de esperar es de esperar que la
presidencia española ponga el acento en
dos asuntos latinoamérica y el sur del
Mediterráneo yo creo que nos va mucho
los españoles y en eso les deseo la
mejor de La suerte es decir que es una
suerte para todos nosotros los españoles
porque una presidencia es de España
no es de Sánchez Es que aquí hay una
equivocación yo noto un poco las
preparativos y espero vuelvo a insistir
Espero que no sea así que sea como las
presidencias que han sido anteriores no
hubo presidencia el señor aznar o
presidencia del Señor zapatero tal igual
Es decir ahora parece que estamos ante
una presencia como muy personalista y de
mucha foto yo espero los contenidos ese
acuerdo con mercosur es vital el pacto
de inmigración es una agenda potente muy
potente estaremos pendientes de eso
Muchísimas gracias a los dos por estar
aquí en Europa hoy a ustedes les
esperamos en el próximo programa de
Europa hoy Gracias por ver France 24 en
español
[Música]